[Music]
what goes up must come down right we've
heard that old saying many times but as
it turns out gravity isn't quite so
simple
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream
in this episode of perspectives four
experts discuss what we know about
gravity as well as some of the things
we're still trying to figure out
we begin now with some of the earliest
theories of gravity by a man often
referred to as the first scientist
aristotle enjoy
[Music]
in the 4th century bc aristotle tried to
describe gravity as being the nature of
matter
his theory revolved around a geocentric
model one in which the earth was in the
center of the universe
the natural location for all matter was
the center hence when things fell
it was explained simply as matter trying
to get to its natural location
other things had other natural locations
fire for example was trying to reach the
heavens which is why flames rise we're
talking about gravity so let's stick
with matter
aristotle's theory of what we might call
terrestrial gravity that is to say the
behavior of gravity here on earth was
simply an instance of objects trying to
get to their natural place
the sky was a different thing the sky
was governed by the gods the sun the
moon the planets comets and stars were
each embedded in one of a series of
concentric spheres centered on the earth
the motion of the heavenly bodies was
caused by the rotation of the spheres
with the rotation made possible by the
intervention of individual gods
there is no concept of what we might
call celestial gravity which is of
course the gravity of the heavens
so aristotle's ideas were developed in
400 bc give or take
now did those evolve over time that's a
long story beyond what we can describe
here but involve some of the great minds
of all times
greek astronomer ptolemy
postulated the earth was at the center
of the universe but imagine something a
little more complicated than aristotle's
spheres
in 1543 polish astronomer copernicus
shook up the astronomical community when
he postulated that the sun and not the
earth was at the center of the universe
the catholic church was not at all happy
with this idea but it stood the test of
time
german astronomer johannes kepler made
additional contributions when he used
precise astronomical observations made
by his mentor tycho brahi to determine
that he could explain the data if the
planets orbited the sun in elliptical
orbits
he also was able to work out the speed
of the various planets and found that
they moved at different speeds while
they orbited it
the penultimate hero in our study of
gravity is italian astronomer and
physicist galileo galilei
he studied both the behavior of matter
here on earth and also in the heavens
legend has it that galileo dropped heavy
and light objects from the leaning tower
of pisa and demonstrated that they fell
at the same rate
this story is a probably apocryphal he
probably drew his conclusions by rolling
objects down ramps but either way he was
right
galileo also studied the heavens and
used the newfangled telescope which he
didn't invent but did lead the way in
using it in astronomy
he found that jupiter has moons which
weighed heavily towards the idea of the
sun and not the earth as being the
center of the universe but again there
was no unifying explanation between how
things fell on earth and how objects
moved in the sky
it was british polymath sir isaac newton
who made the truly crucial advance
newton was one of the smartest and most
scientifically influential people of all
times
the number of things he was able to
explain is simply staggering however
from the gravity point of view
what he did was come up with a model
that successfully demonstrated that
celestial and terrestrial gravity were
one and the same
we call his gravity model newton's law
of universal gravity for just that
reason
he worked out the idea that two objects
would feel a mutual gravitational force
governed by the mass of the two objects
and the distance between them well the
distance squared actually
but newton's law as successful as it is
is also quite mysterious
let me emphasize it is very successful
newton's law of gravity is all you need
to get to the moon and back if you want
to travel around the solar system you
want to figure out how the planets move
except for the tiny little exception of
mercury which is closest to the sun
where we need general relativity
einstein's theory of gravity but for the
rest of the solar system newton's theory
of gravity is very good but it's
mysterious and newton himself recognized
this the reason why it's mysterious is
how do the planets know
how strong the gravitational force is
supposed to be
it's as if gravity is reaching out over
empty space with nothing in between
from the sun to the planets and saying
here's the force that is acting on you
newton was very bothered by this this is
called action at a distance and newton
himself didn't like it if you read his
masterwork principia mathematica newton
himself will say i don't know why
there is this action at a distance
involved with gravity i leave it to
future generations to finally figure it
out but in fact it didn't take very long
not long after newton in the around the
year 1800 a french mathematician and
physicist named pierre simone laplace
came up with a slightly different theory
of gravity
now laplace's theory of gravity is not
one that you may have ever heard of
because basically it's exactly the same
as newton's theory in all of its
experimental predictions once you have
newton's inverse square law laplace is
not giving you a different law he's
giving you a different way to get the
same law and what laplace says is
instead of just thinking of a
gravitational force think of a field
pervading space
think of a number at every point in
space which laplace called the
gravitational potential field
and in laplace's version of gravity he
replaces newton's equations with
equations for this gravitational
potential field and he says two things
number one a big massive object warps
the field by pushing on the field it
changes its value
and then number two the slope of the
field the amount by which the field is
changing gives you the force due to
gravity
so you can think of a
hillside or something like that with a
slope where the distance by which the
field is changing the distance by which
the the sharpness of the hill tells you
the force that is acting on you
now the answer you get for what the
force is is exactly the same in
laplace's view and in newton's view but
the difference is
that the plos does not have action at a
distance instead the field is everywhere
so the sun affects the field nearby and
that affects the field near to that and
that affects the field near to that all
the way throughout the whole universe
in laplace's version of gravity there's
no action at a distance there's a field
that is everywhere even though you don't
see it
and that is what gives rise to the force
of gravity
before einstein physicists thought of
gravity simply as a force that attracts
massive objects toward one another
and in a sense this is correct
gravity does pull us downward and toward
the earth and gravity keeps the earth in
its orbit by pulling it toward the sun
but this view of gravity the newtonian
view
fails to recognize the greater
significance of the phenomenon we call
gravity
what einstein had discovered is that
gravity is not merely a force
but is instead the very manifestation of
the shape or geometry of space and time
according to einstein the presence of
mass and other energy
changes the geometry of the surrounding
space and time curving or warping it
and this curving or warping causes
objects to move through space
differently than they would have
otherwise
when an object moves through space far
away from any massive bodies and without
being pulled or pushed by any forces
it simply moves forward in a straight
line
well according to einstein when the
earth moves in its orbit around the sun
it too is moving in a straight line
the presence of the sun
has reshaped the geometry of the solar
system
bending space
and transforming the earth's trajectory
gravity isn't a force at all according
to einstein
it's geometry
which is a consequence of mass and
energy
by explaining gravity in terms of
geometry einstein overturned hundreds of
years of established physics
furthermore his theory was not only
profoundly creative and mathematically
elegant it is also right
by this i mean that the predictions of
this theory agree extremely well with
any number of observations that have
been made
shortly after he completed his general
theory of relativity in 1915 einstein
reached the conclusion that moving
objects could under certain
circumstances create ripples or
vibrations in the very fabric of space
and time
these rippling waves carry energy and
they propagate through space at the
speed of light
at some level this isn't too surprising
that einstein's field equations allow
for the formation and propagation of
gravitational waves
as a point of comparison consider the
equations that physicists use to
describe the phenomena of electricity
and magnetism these are known as
maxwell's equations
one of the solutions of maxwell's
equations is a combination of an
oscillating electric and an oscillating
magnetic field
together these time-varying electric and
magnetic fields move through space at
the speed of light
in fact this combination of oscillating
electric and magnetic fields is nothing
more than the thing that we actually
call light
light is itself an electromagnetic wave
in close analogy to this einstein's
field equations have solutions which
correspond to a propagating wave of
oscillating curvature of space-time
these gravitational waves travel through
space at the same speed as light and
they require no medium other than that
of space and time itself
initially most physicists thought that
gravitational waves are probably real
although although they knew that they'd
be very difficult to detect or study
but gradually attitudes toward
gravitational waves began to shift
towards skepticism and even disbelief
for example in 1922 the famous physicist
and astronomer arthur eddington wrote a
paper in which he argued against the
existence of gravitational waves
arguing that the solutions to the field
equations were mere mathematical
artifacts and that they didn't have any
self-consistent physical meaning
when einstein made his first
calculations involving gravitational
waves back in 1916
he had used a common method of
approximation known as perturbation
theory
in the 1930s he became interested once
again in this kind of phenomena but this
time he was determined to avoid the use
of any approximations
instead einstein wanted to find exact
gravitational wave solutions to his
field equations
this led einstein to reach a very
different conclusion than the one he had
reached back in 1916.
after taking all the details of the math
into account
einstein became convinced that nothing
like a stable propagating gravitational
wave could really exist
instead he thought that gravitational
waves were just a mathematical artifact
that was somehow connected to the
approximations that he had made in the
earlier versions of his calculations
he now thought that any gravitational
waves would instantly collapse
such a failed wave couldn't possibly
carry any energy and it wouldn't have
any measurable effects
about all of this we now know that
einstein was simply wrong
in february of 2016 an international
group of scientists announced one of the
most exciting discoveries ever seen in
astrophysics
after months of analysis they had
reached a remarkable conclusion
five months earlier two of the world's
most sensitive physics experiments in
eastern washington state and southeast
louisiana had detected gravitational
waves
both sites had picked up the fleeting
but unmistakable signal of two black
holes
29 and 36 times the mass of our sun
colliding and merging 1.4 billion light
years away
the cataclysmic event had set off
ripples in the fabric of space-time
traveling at the speed of light and
arriving at earth on the morning of
september 14 2015.
coincidentally the discovery came 100
years after the theory of general
relativity was published when einstein
himself predicted the phenomenon but
also despaired of ever detecting it
his theory had demonstrated that
gravitational waves should exist
but it also revealed that they would be
absurdly minute
seemingly imperceptible perturbations in
the fabric of space-time that would
surely be impossible to measure with any
human-made machine
a century later decades of effort from
an enormous team of scientists and
engineers would make the impossible
happen
since that first announcement
gravitational wave astronomy has evolved
from groundbreaking to almost
commonplace
new detections once closely guarded
secrets are now announced on social
media almost as soon as they happen
we've found more pairs of black holes
detected merging neutron stars and even
begun to spot hints of other more exotic
gravitational phenomena
in just a few years we've already
learned a great deal about gravitational
waves and the colliding objects that
produce them and we're facing a bright
future in this young and exciting field
to understand how these waves work i
want you to imagine that you're holding
a slinky between your hands
if you look at that slinky there's two
different ways that you could cause a
wave
one is the obvious way you could take
the slinky lift one end and watch a
curved wave propagate from one end to
the other
but this isn't quite how gravitational
waves work
gravitational waves are more like
compression waves propagating through
space-time
if you instead hold the slinky and
briefly bring one hand closer to the
other you'll make a different type of
wave
this one squeezes and stretches the
coils of the slinky as it travels and
this is the best way to imagine a
gravitational wave
gravitational waves travel at the speed
of light and squeeze and stretch
space-time itself along with everything
in it
this includes our own planet
as a gravitational wave passes through
earth we'll be squeezed and stretched as
well
we don't understand how gravity works in
the realm of the super small
now this is kind of weird we know of
four fundamental forces
according to at least some ways of
counting they are gravity
electromagnetism and the strong and weak
nuclear forces
we know a great deal about the last
three in the quantum world
for those forces scientists have had a
great degree of success envisioning them
as subatomic matter particles exchanging
a force-carrying particle
for example in electromagnetism when two
electrons bounce into one another the
classical explanation is that both
electrons generate an electric field and
the electrons feel each other's fields
this leads to the path of the two
electrons being deflected
in the quantum world of electromagnetism
what happens is a little different
as the two electrons approach one
another one of the electrons emits a
photon
that electron recoils and then changes
the direction it's moving
the photon then travels to the other
electron which absorbs it
when the electron absorbs the photon the
direction traveled by the second
electron
also changes
in quantum mechanics you can't know even
in principle which electron emitted the
photon and which absorbed it and the
recoil is due to ordinary momentum
conservation that you might have learned
in an introductory physics class
if you never took physics don't worry
about it momentum conservation is just a
fancy way of describing that if you're
standing in a boat in the middle of a
lake and dive into the water the boat
moves in a direction opposite to the
direction you dove
the most important thing to remember is
that at the quantum level forces like
electromagnetism and the strong and weak
nuclear forces are best described by a
matter particle emitting a
force-carrying particle which is then
absorbed by another matter particle
the specifics of the matter particles
and force-carrying particles change for
the various forces but you don't need to
sweat those details it's the exchange
that matters
that's how quantum forces work
the same motivation that required the
creation of ordinary quantum mechanics
also means that there must be a solution
of some sort to the answer of the
problems of gravitational radiation in
general
relativity now does that mean that
quantum gravity must be similar to
ordinary quantum mechanics well no it
doesn't in fact technically i guess you
don't even need to call it quantum
gravity but there are two things that
are true
the first is that there needs to be a
solution to the problem of the stability
of atoms to gravitational radiation
and the second is that general
relativity falls apart when it's applied
to the world of the very small
what we can prove is that at scales like
the planck time length and energy the
gravitational effects that we always
ignore are no longer ignorable
this has to be the size scale where
quantum gravity absolutely must become
important although of course it could
become important at larger scales but
it's mandatory at these scales
furthermore while it might be possible
to look at space at shorter distances it
will require a completely new physical
paradigm with new laws equations the
whole enchilada
okay so that's the deal about quantum
gravity it is clear that general
relativity breaks in the quantum world
it predicts infinities
and even if we somehow come up with a
better theory of gravity at the plank
length and time we have to take quantum
effects into account
what they will be we don't know but what
we do know is that the future of quantum
gravity will be truly fascinating
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
on one dream and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel for
new episodes of perspectives and you can
watch previous ones here